[Music]
[Laughter]
you got your prospective
[Music]
so let the Vayner sports superbowl
basketball game we don't we shoot around
we can't get our athlete Johnny to if we
can't let this man get hurt so they can
just shoot around but we're gonna play
for real
[Music]
Oh
we have the dark clouds with the polo
Sox just you know ideal elbow jumper
get up you know so AJ AJ knows AJ knows
we gonna drive the lane see me add elbow
I'm Barry the fairy the biscuit it's
gonna go weekend last night was good
Thursday meet and greet that's mr.
Justin G and Grande he feels
exponentially cooler based on the
outcome of last night what she deserves
we got to get an interview oh it's
Justin gene grant
Justin G likes cutoff shirts he's a
cut-off shirt guy you know I was never
really a cutoff shirt guy he's also
mic'd up you know we run from their
magazine you know my man Carlos Gill
Matty DeMaio getting buckets in the
cardigan cardigan never heard nobody
looks like he's actually a flannel line
jeans on it's a good look by him
yeah
[Music]
oh it's a great way to work off yeah
are you teaching Isis it's a great way
to work off last night that's the main
thing
she's nice break a sweat and I'm a great
shooter I can't do much else
my single athletic ability
[Music]
we were hoping this is the am hoops
Super Bowl pop-up edition over here
we're about to shoot some pours and
started this tradition last year in
Minnesota AJ was the king last year see
if we can oh he's calling he's calling
his shot apparently AJ has already
claimed the throne but you know we're
gonna hoop we got all our clients out
here at Vayner Sports 10 of the guys
gonna play some games and just kind of
unwind a little bit Super Bowl week gets
super hectic a good way to kind of get a
stretch and just reset
yet literally the two days before I met
Mike I have 30 tabs open on my firefox
of un wrappers and I was trying to
figure out what was going on I was like
how did this dude have gone out on a
podcast like six months before anyone
knew who gonna what and then literally
two days later I was that tree sounds I
met Mike and he was like oh yeah I work
with Gary and you're like but do you but
you know what but it's an important
story cuz you know we've actually been
doing a version of it since 2009 which
is amazing yeah like it's not like you
know no it's not new I know I get and
that's why it works but and like being
there last night it's just like never
wrote [ __ ] so it's just like it's it's
an amazing thing like last night so many
of the players were like wait these guys
know you know I was like they're my
friend friend friend
[Music]
this is like watching the office what
this is really good this is better than
I thought it would be you great yeah
yeah it's also cool like you know you're
talking about it like a shot at this
point it was so early on these first
couple right so it's like well I it's
more the office you know we gotta we
gotta bring that back I agree it's
better
one thing I underestimated is what its
gonna be feeling like let's watch Oh
[Laughter]
Tyler what's your favorite episode of
daily oh my god go back oh my god
this is incredible ready nope go back to
the look at this look at the cat up here
well wow that's really like you knew
Harley at this point yeah but it's it's
so cool I think over it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
shut up now no when they do combos one
simple Gary Vee
[Music]